PRERNA BELLARA: Look,
unicorns do exist.
STEPHANIE WONG: Psh.
We all know unicorns
are mythical creatures,
whereas dinosaurs actually
did graze the very land we're
standing on.
PRERNA BELLARA: OK, well,
before we go back and forth
about our own existence, the
real question of the decade
is, do you know where your
sensitive data exists?
Or is it a myth that your
PII and sensitive information
are going back and forth,
and your company will never
be leaked?
STEPHANIE WONG: It
sounds like we can prove
that that's actually a myth.
PRERNA BELLARA: Indeed, it is.
But Google's Data
Loss Prevention API
can help classify and redact
information at the source.
Enough of us talking.
Let's jump into a demo.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So this is a great opportunity
for talking about the Data Loss
Prevention API.
And it's a need of
the hour, right?
In a way.
Because if you
think about it, it's
reported that 2.5
quintillion bytes of data
are generated every day.
That's a lot of information, and
a lot of sensitive information
that is generated by users
and millennials like you
and I. In fact, I
was told that 90%
of the data that
we're using today
was generated just in
the last few years.
Now, where does
DLP come into play?
Whenever we're talking
to our company in HR,
or whenever we're talking
to our credit card
company or our
credit score company,
we tend to exchange some
sensitive information,
such as our phone numbers,
our social security numbers,
ZIP code, date of
birth, et cetera.
DLP helps you classify
and redact information.
How does it do that?
DLP API will traverse
through your raw data,
classify it into a social
security number, phone number,
and--
there are about 40 or 50
types of classifications
like this that you can
see on the website.
It redacts that
information, and then
lets you use it for
further analysis,
secure sharing
within your company,
and for app development.
Let's look at an app
development section.
There's a situation that
we've all seen before, right?
There's a customer
agent, and there's
Alice, who's a customer,
who's trying to get an Anvil
application to work correctly.
Neil has asked her
for the last four
digits of her social security
number and contact information.
Alice has clearly overshared.
She's not only given her
entire social security number,
she's given her email
address and a photo
of her social security card.
Now, enterprises want to
store this information
for further data
analysis and improvement.
But if they store
this, they're exposing
Alice's private information
to the entire organization.
And they can
potentially get sued.
Alice can potentially
lose her social security
and her identity.
How do we fix that?
As soon as we click
End Chat, our DLP API
runs in the background,
traverses through this chat,
and redacts the information.
You can see that the phone
number has been masked.
Her social security
has been masked.
Only the last four digits
have been maintained.
Her email address is
completely blocked out.
And this is one of
my favorite features.
The social security number,
despite it being a photo,
the numbers have been masked.
And it's classifying it as a
social security number, as well
as the likelihood that this is
a very likely chance of being
a social security number.
Like that, you have others,
like US Census names.
And all of this
information can now
be stored very easily
into their database.
Now, let's look at what it
looks like behind the scene.
There's a Google
Cloud Storage bucket.
Yes, it's in the cloud, which
has all your raw data, right?
We're looking at an
examples right now,
which has customer data,
HR data, and a mix of data.
There's what the data
looks like in real life.
There's a customer ID,
their first name, last name,
and some comments.
These are just garbage
comments, but you
can see that there are some
numbers over there that
resemble a social
security number,
or somebody's phone number,
or a credit card number.
Let's see how DLP
handles this information,
because when we're
storing this information,
we don't want to store
their email address
or their social security number.
All of this information,
after it is run through DLP,
we store it into BigQuery.
This is what the data
looks like after DLP
has redacted the information.
You can see it gives you the
table name, the row number,
it tells you that it
was in column comments,
and this was the value.
And it was an email address,
and it was very likely
that it was an email address.
So now you know the row which
has sensitive information
and the value.
So the next time you want
to move this information
from one place to
another, you will
be cognizant to remove
the value or to be
wary of sharing this
information, or at least
this row.
This was another query that
our team came up with just
to show the number of
occurrences of each attribute
type and the percentage.
This, again, is in BigQuery.
You can see it's a
three-line query that's
just coming up
with a small metric
that we have come
up with ourselves.
STEPHANIE WONG: Wow, I don't
know what's more magical--
you, or the DLP API.
PRERNA BELLARA: But
don't be fooled.
The DLP API is not a myth.
It's an API, like
the name suggests,
that prevents unauthorized
users from sending
sensitive or unauthorized data.
STEPHANIE WONG: Can't
get more real than that.
Thanks again, Prerna.
PRERNA BELLARA: Sure.
Please comment, like,
and subscribe below.
STEPHANIE WONG: And if you'd
like to get in contact with us,
check out the link below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]